you know I'm gonna be honest with you I
just film an entire video with a booger
hanging out of my nose I'm doing it
again sinan Indianapolis basking in the
afterglow of a nerdfighter event
watching election returns it's too early
to say anything so I'm just not gonna
say anything what I am gonna say is that
I hate election night I would really
like to be able to sleep right now
watching an election is like watching a
football game that you really care about
except one not interesting the score
changes but nothing happens you never
get to see Warrick Dunn do a backflip
over the refrigerator you never get to
see them amazing visceral strength of
well-trained well-oiled young men each
other on the behinds this isn't coming
out the way I wanted it to sound we
don't get to see that here we just get
to be annoyed and scared and to the
winner of the game doesn't have direct
implications of the future the entire
world oh hello there Hank how are you
today hi John what did you what are you
talking about talking to dad about the
fact that it was Bill no longer housing
jobs thanks to dad yeah dad for not
voting for Elizabeth Dole mom and mom
English not be partisan we just don't
like Elizabeth all I'm wearing my
Montana grid shirt because it resulted
in the election of seven finger Jon
Tester in 2006 he hangs loose 100% of
the time
so I hear I am annoyed and scared in
Indianapolis and you know what else I am
a rican tired the Tour de nerdfighting
has been absolutely fantastic but it
hasn't included a lot of sleeping I hope
all of you who are 18 or older voted
today because obviously this is a
historic day and no an elections going
well and John Green is and vomiting John
Green is not vomiting I didn't want to
say one little thing yesterday and
John's video he said at my CD would only
be available on the Tour de nerdfighting
and that is not entirely true
it is only currently available on the
Tour de nerdfighting after we get off
the tour we're gonna set up a shipping
apparatus and everything so we can sell
them online and ship them out hopefully
in early December see Harry the
nerdfighters hi look I've got a Willie
hi hi hi hi how much licking I mean
we're not political here on the vlog
brothers right Willie but uh sometimes
you just gotta show you true colors I
think I'm just gonna upload this maybe
there will be a special update a little
bit later so that we can come to you
any news that might be actually official
so John I'll see you in like 30 seconds
or so and nerdfighters you'll see John
on the road to Louisville Kentucky
tomorrow